this is thorough Thanks
I just want to thank you all I'm coming
on the cultivating spirit sensational
fusion experience we're gonna have a
wonderful evening
tonight we will head over to high
country hearing for an exclusive
dispensary experience and also to go
over our recommended cannabis pairing of
the night and then we'll head over to
the frisco wine merchant when we'll go
through multiple types of wine that is
all geared towards our gourmet meal that
we're gonna have later on in the evening
Colorado's recreational marijuana
industry is booming the state voted to
legalize recreational weed in 2012 it
became the first to start selling it in
January 2014 sales have doubled since
then reaching more than thirty million
dollars a month I've come here to see
how the industry is shaping up which I'm
learning involves participating in some
surprisingly high-end experiences so
sativa in the most part is energetic
uplifting you for it you smoke this you
can get your peak in ten minutes
the indica full-body effect from head to
toe you can feel really relaxed like
sedated a very heavy indica can also
give you couch lock where you're just
done pecker snacks on hand within 15
minutes otherwise you're not gonna eat
you have to smell this so it's got like
a piney citrusy scent on the exhale
you're gonna taste strawberry and it's a
very intense Cerebral head high lighter
and brighter visual characteristics of
it as well
by the way all our plants are grown
organic and soil their hand water hand
shrimp and all the plants listen to
music throughout their lives it's a lot
like the wine tasting look yeah yeah you
know you can really come up with all the
different identifying characteristics of
it yeah I feel more that Mandarin very
subtle and then with a really piney
aftertaste to it
[Music]
surging demand for cannabis products and
services is putting money in the pockets
of a whole new class of entrepreneurs in
the mile-high state so right now you may
not be able to see the smoke but there's
a very thick smell of orange it's a lot
like Tang it's very sweet I didn't
actually smoke myself but I feel like I
did the munchies are setting in but
there's no pizza or fast food on the
cultivating spirit store instead we stop
for a three-course dinner prepared by a
gourmet cannabis chef
[Music]
[Applause]
the guests on our tour Colorado
professionals looking to learn more
about the finer side of cannabis when
people throw this phrase around pot
barons I mean is there a class emerging
in Colorado fit the description is there
people who are gonna be millionaires off
of this definitely you know is their
dispensary owners who've probably made a
million dollars this year definitely
everyone who wants to throw around who's
gonna be the first pot billionaire and
there are a lot of investors coming out
here yeah there are a lot of investors
coming out here and really trying to hit
you know the Green Rush is what they're
calling it and it's great because it's
adding a lot of validity to our you know
to this industry it's a whirlwind really
it's it's kind of crazy that it's you
know that the industry has come this far
if we're excited to be in the forefront
Jenifer DiFalco and Olivia Mannix are
the founders of canna brand a boutique
consulting firm that wants to help both
industry veterans and newcomers polish
their image and all of our marketing we
steer clear of all the cliches that
people associate with its cannabis
consumption we're trying to just get rid
of those labels and get rid of those
stigmas associated with labels so that
anyone who consumes doesn't feel the
burden of a stigma or a label so can you
tell us a little bit about this
advertisement here I can't a sewer
basically of someone who knows good
cannabis just like the molière someone
way better connoisseur of cannabis if I
ask you what your brand identity is what
would you say we're the new cannabis
consumer yeah
we're bridging the gap between the
traditional cannabis consumer in the new
cannabis consumer Jenna brand holds
branding strategy sessions with their
clients as I watch one I can't help but
notice that so far this up-and-coming
industry has looked overwhelmingly white
I think the most important thing is to
have your product be quality from the
back end to the front end
Wanda James is a veteran cannabis
activist and former dispensary owner the
cannabis industry is clearly booming in
Colorado
right now why do you think people of
color is so reticent to get involved I
think one in the black of around
communities because we have been so
beaten up by police harassment over the
use of cannabis there is still a
definitive fear of jumping into it
because I think people think well what
happens if we get a new president or
with the laws changed and we're all
gonna go back to jail again
do you feel that it's still too soon
that there's a lot of stigma and fear
because of past experience that no one
really trusts that they can have a
meaningful role in this industry and
make a legitimate living that's exactly
the issue because you know if your dad
was arrested in to time in prison you're
gonna be a lot less likely to do what
got your dad arrested which is now
making people millions of dollars it's
suspect it's suspect and once again
black and brown communities don't trust
our government they definitely don't
trust law enforcement and for our family
we've seen that happen in real life my
brother was arrested at 17 and got given
a felony in the state of Texas my
brother received a 10-year sentence for
four and a half ounces of cannabis and
his story is not unique
there's 850 thousand of those stories
across the nation all the time
black and brown mostly boys between the
ages of 17 and 24 are the target wasn't
Dylan once he was smoking was partying
on us and kicking it was kid Wanda's
brother Rick spent more than six years
in a federal penitentiary area on
possession charges
everybody at penitentiary works no
matter what it is you working on because
of why was that not saying I was picking
cotton
yeah a teenager picking cotton in Texas
yes sir twelve years of slavery
I had three three and a half no pick
cotton every day every day they wake you
up at five o'clock in the morning gather
you up everybody go out pick hunt can't
come back with less than a hundred pound
you're coming back into society you're a
felon what was life like for you I tried
to do the right thing you know get a job
or get a job during being a felon on
saying Wes dening reoccurred what it was
she's just a felon so excellent you're
back
they don't want to take the chance today
Rick manages his sister's restaurant
he'd prefer to work with cannabis but
under current state law people with drug
convictions are barred from working in
the industry for ten years you start
going through the process of Ananse and
figuring out what the laws were and what
I had to do to like grow weed and stuff
like that and went down and they told me
my saying because of my situation Ross
and I couldn't get the license to where
we so it wasn't her but
it's not a bad view okay it's probably
prettiest view in the state
Jonathan singer is a pro cannabis state
representative he's never smoked pot in
his life chocolate chip cookie seven
servings uh so these are pot cookies
right here on the steps of the Capitol
well you can see our our our regulations
have worked insofar as they you know are
in opaque containers that aren't
attractive to kids but doesn't there's
no warning label for littering I'm still
pretty sure that's illegal
yeah this one's got 70 milligrams active
THC oh wow
these yours Mac not yet in regulating
the industry you want to show the
federal government that you were serious
here
people with past criminal offenses are
restricted from entering the industry do
you feel like there was an overreaction
the way some of that law came out in a
bid to say look people you know we're
serious about this you know III think it
was it was a responsible reaction but
have also an overreaction and we didn't
have the guidance from the federal
government as to whether they were gonna
come in and stamp all this out with
federal raids we wanted to take the the
most stringent steps possible to make
sure that any criminal element wasn't
involved at the end of the day though
when you look at winners and losers and
in the recreational marijuana market the
people that were left out were the
people that were probably most affected
by the failed experiment of the drug war
singer is now part of a push to bring
about industry reforms notably reversing
punitive measures for activities that
are now legal which by extension would
open up the legal pot industry to people
who have been excluded the second step
then is to find an easy path for people
who committed nonviolent drug crimes
that maybe still have it on their record
they aren't in jail but it's still on
their record to make sure that they have
an easy simple path to seal those
records they can petition a judge to say
you know look no it was it was a stupid
mistake that wouldn't even be considered
a stupid mistake anymore yeah this is
the historic black neighborhood in the
city of Denver art ways the Colorado
State Director of the drug policy
Alliance I grew up in a high crime area
so called gang ridden area around here
all the violence that I suffered as a
key
it came at the hands of police you know
I had a cop put a gun to my head when I
was like 11 years old I've heard that
people of color are two-and-a-half times
more likely to get arrested on drug
charges than your average white person
out here what does that say about where
things stand it's all about selective
enforcement that's what's so unjust
about the drug war this is about people
being discriminated against and certain
policies being used to basically
continue historical disenfranchisement
of certain communities you don't really
see a lot of owners of dispensaries or
grows or people of color why do you
think that is right now people grew up
in certain neighborhoods that were
highly saturated with police it's just
hard to escape those areas without maybe
a minor marijuana possession charge and
that charge of follow them and prevent
them from being in the industry and then
it just takes a lot of capital to get
involved something there's something
going on with the Attorney General's and
DA's you know they're supposed to
represent the people but they could be a
lot more friendly I mean a lot more
understanding based on what the science
is telling us regarding at least
marijuana but you know they're kind of
stuck in the 80s and you know the old
school kind of propaganda around the
harms of marijuana
[Music]
have you ever smoked pot before I have
not John Suthers is Colorado's Attorney
General I really do believe that
culturally embracing getting high for
recreational purposes is a very bad
message for young people I don't think
it's good public policy as the war on
drugs failed it depends upon your your
perspective I look at the fact that in
1979 14% of Americans had used an
illicit drug in the last 30 days we got
that all the way down about 5% by 1992
and it's been gradually moving back up
there's a bill out there now that would
mandate the sealing of records of people
who serve time for offenses that are now
legal would you stand the way of
something like that it depends upon the
nature of the offense if they want to
seal a 15 year old marijuana conviction
for possession of an ounce or something
like that I don't have a problem with
that the Attorney General's Office wants
to limit the scope of the record ceiling
bill keeping it narrowly focused on
minor pot convictions I could be a drug
war dinosaur no question about it I'm
perfectly willing to admit that and I'm
perfectly comfortable with that role I
mean that's part of generational change
but I I'm not so sure that 10 years from
now the majority of Coloradans are going
to think this was a great idea for now
though the people involved in this
highbrow pot industry couldn't disagree
more and this is what is locally known
as the Green Mile there are 17
dispensaries on the stretch of road
right here it said that there are more
marijuana dispensaries in Denver than
there are Starbucks and this is ground
zero for that the amazing benefits of
this plant it has the potential to
really change the world and I get real
excited about that for the next
generation it's really high energy it's
just a new industry and it's definitely
the survival of the fittest
as I say there are tons and tons and
tons of people
want to invest in cannabis because it's
a good business I've been offered
investments all the time even those who
know the exclusion the legalization is
causing or positive anybody who does not
think that cannabis has not been an
amazing positive quite frankly is
operating with their head in the sand
dropping crime drop in T news seventy
five million dollars will come from tax
revenue to the state of Colorado we've
created over 10,000 jobs over 1,000
businesses 2,000 growth facilities this
is a model for the rest of the country
this is the model for the rest of the
country
[Music]